SO I THINK I GAVE HIM A PASS ON
THAT.
NOW FLASH FORWARD MANY YEARS.
I THINK LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE I
WAS REALLY GIVING BILL THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
THIS WAS NOT THE MAN THAT I
KNEW.
THIS IS NOT THE MAN THAT I
WORKED WITH.
HE MAY HAVE HAD OTHER FAULTS BUT
HE CERTAINLY WAS NOT DRUGGING
AND RAPING PEOPLE.
AND THEN I HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH AN OLD FRIEND, BUMPED INTO
HER.
I HADN'T TALKED TO HER IN A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
I JUST THOUGHT, HEY, HE USED TO
BE LIKE YOUR MENTOR OR
SOMETHING.
>> WAS SHE AN ACTRESS?
>> YEAH.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SAY TOO MUCH
ABOUT HER.
>> WHAT DID SHE SAY?
>> FOR TWO HOURS SHE SAT IN MY
CAR CRYING, TELLING ME HER
STORY, ALL OF THE DETAILS.
AND AT THAT MOMENT SOMETHING
CHANGED FOR ME.
SHE TURNED TO ME AND SHE SAID --
SHE WIPED HER FACE AND SHE SAID,
DO YOU BELIEVE ME?
AND I SAID, YES, I BELIEVE YOU.
AND THAT WAS THE CHANGE.
AND I HAD TO